because if time is of the essence
literally especially EMT every second
that time is of the essence every second
wasted I'm like this is 10 minutes gone
like this my child is about to die
[Music]
our last uh last OTR and then one more
article after this okay stop touching
three two
three two one oh that is so [__] up oh
what do you mean what'd you say about me
you said about your ears no nothing
happened so the guy was [__] up here
is good here
I heard it you know what's crazy I
didn't even say it I just I heard your
thoughts I said A blank sentence with no
words and you heard it yeah that's
amazing just don't talk to me during
this OTR okay
don't ask me anything
all right
three two
whatever we'll just leave it in like
that
here's a question that gets asked a lot
through the IG the sometimes the Discord
but mainly through just like regular
people hitting up the JK IG is how does
everybody feel about college like what
are your thoughts on College how
necessary is it do you advice
hottestate goes first go college no no I
think we talked about it in an earlier
video yeah your like college experience
uh I had a really bratty shitty attitude
about it because I thought I was wasting
time
you weren't learning anything new as a
Kinesiology major not stuff once again
the lens of what I was looking at was
very like entitled and very like what do
they really say like because some of the
stuff you just feel like dude you're
just making me jump through hoops like
that aren't gonna matter like you think
like that you think like oh this is how
I thought and I think it's not really
that uncommon to think like that when
you're going to school
um I just felt like there was no point I
was just wasting time I really wanted to
be working I didn't want to be here
so um
for sure there were some classes that I
thought were [__] maybe because of
the professors maybe not because of the
subject matter but just how they would
teach it and they just felt like they
were going through the motions you know
but until I found like professors that I
really liked that were passionate about
the subject that made therefore me
passionate about it yeah I was like all
right cool I think it wasn't until I
felt like I got challenged where I felt
like okay cool I'm into this I want to
work hard and I want to like do well in
this aspect but once I left College I
felt like I was glad I did it but the
farther I got on in my life I realized
like oh it was actually very valuable
for me to go to school and I got the
opportunity that a lot of kids don't get
to be able to just be supported through
learning and helping my craft later on
in life too but during the time I
definitely didn't think it was worth it
I definitely thought I was a waste of
time and I think it that's an argument
to be made depending on what you want to
do in your life
um but I think it like I said earlier I
have way more positive experiences from
it than I do negative so as a
um in fighting or in training or in um
even in like weight loss coaching do you
feel like some Kinesiology knowledge
that you gained in college applies I
think it helped out a lot cool
definitely that's something that a lot
not a lot of people can say about there
but at the time I didn't feel that way
like I was just just being stupid though
I was being a young you know ignorant
kid but not much has changed
thank you
I disrespected me
just for no reason yeah right that's
good and you're not gonna say anything
just stab her up dude
if if you say another thing about me
that's not really me I mean that's not
really nice
it's nervous now with all the spots wait
a second
enjoying it I'm gonna walk into traffic
and I'm gonna blame it on you
I hope you do I can't wait to get blamed
for that
so let's say um what would your advice
be to a person that's debating like in
in a very short sentence like if someone
says very short very short
uh if he's like should I stay in college
or just follow my passions elevator
pitch now go I don't believe in short
pictures dude I don't believe in it
because I think context really matters
like whether it's coaching or whoever
you're talking to yeah you got to meet
people where they're at yeah so you have
to kind of understand what their end
goal is or if they don't know what their
what like a per like I think most people
you talk to when it comes to school they
don't know what they want to do right
because they haven't tried enough things
because I used to think like okay once
you do this one thing
that'll be what you do forever kind of
like that's what you think in your head
especially when you're young it's also
hard when you haven't seen the careers
yeah like I didn't know [__] about any
career I tried an EMT class yeah I was
like I thought I was gonna be EMT I did
that for like a couple weeks and I was
like dude I don't think I have the
stomach for I don't think I could do
this like you as an EMT would be pretty
interesting yeah dude I couldn't I was
like I'm out dude Did we tell you about
our stuttering EMT
was it me no what happened EMT [__]
sidetracked but so uh taika had his
second seizure okay at this point
um between the first seizure and the
seizure there was six months so we
didn't think he was getting seizures we
thought at this the second time around
we thought he was choking on something
so he was blue in the face
um yeah and I had to call 9-1-1 so the
EMT comes and um at this point we're
like what the [__] are we gonna need to
give a CPR we're trying to sort
everything out the [__] ENT that's
giving us all the information is
stuttering and in any other how bad
really bad really [__] bad like a
diagnosis this guy has a stutter ring
like that like if you just can't get it
out and I'm going what the [__] is going
on with my kid is he like dying like can
we get it like what is happening and
he's stuttering and normally I don't
care because I mean it's a stutter it's
not a big deal but in a case of an
emergency like that I'm like bro he
cannot be the one because if time is of
the essence literally especially EMT
every second that time is of the essence
every second wasted I'm like this is 10
minutes gone like this my child is about
to die so that's yeah it's the kind he
stutters so bad he's the kind that like
blinks every syllable like
yeah and I was like what the [__] yeah
seizure like that oh and normally again
just tell them you're like we know he
has a seizure but what oh no we didn't
know oh at the time
oh sorry no he wasn't breathing or
responding and this guy's trying to
explain it to me and I'm going [__]
[__] can someone else pieces [__]
time what the [__] is going on and I was
like literally talking that fast
anyway sorry but I like your answer
just if you have a stuttering problem
that's yeah maybe not that but like I
had to try a different I had to work I'd
volunteer at the hospital for a little
bit I realized I was like I don't think
I want to work at a hospital like this
is really sad like delivering patience
across to you know different wings and
then like bringing stuff to like the
NICU like it was it was like tough dude
you see all these kids in like G tubes
and all this kind of stuff you're like
oh I do not want to be around because
like you would just feel this energy
that I was like I don't think I want to
be around this too consistently but
until I landed where I was where I was
like okay this is what I want to do yeah
and I was sure of it because I tried
other things that I was like for sure I
don't want to do yeah yeah I think if
you're gonna go to college I'm a big
advocate for college I think uh for some
people they don't need it and I'm like
that's really cool but I'm not someone
that didn't need it
um for me it because I was so sheltered
at home I really I didn't get to take
advantage of it now kind of in
retrospect
um I wish I would have taken College
more of like um kind of like the buffet
of what the world has to offer
um but then with that also comes cost so
if you can afford to do that that's
super that's super good element for sure
um because you can try different
languages you can try different Majors
you can try different hobbies and like
you can and you're meeting so many
different study abroad study abroad all
of that right like you you meet so many
different people from so many different
walks of life that you really don't get
to meet outside in the real world right
because in the real world now you have
to like make a living or like I don't
know pay bills or do whatever reality
sets in yeah um but when you're in
college you're kind of like in this
really cool protected bubble where
people have kind of the same mindset of
like they're trying to be better at life
um so like I wish when I was in college
I wish I wasn't in such a rush
you know where I'm like [__] I just want
to finish and I just want to get into my
career and like I'm 20 something like
what the [__] do you really know
um but there are some people like my
brother that was like I just want to
like work with my hands like I don't
want to do any of this [__] so he really
early on like for him was like I don't
want college I just want to build my own
business up and you know I want to be an
electrician and I want to like I love
this [__] and he just got out of it
that's a blessing to know what you want
to do yeah I had no idea what I wanted
to do yeah
um but yeah I think for certain people
if you can afford to do it which is
again a bummer but I think there's
scholarships and a bunch of stuff now
that you can apply for but
um I I would say like dude experience it
be in a frat or an absority like get
into different activities go to these
parties like just have fun yeah the
experiences yeah it's a big difference
it's unmatched that's really cool that
your brother uh he went to trade school
yes that's I'm a big proponent for trade
schools like I'm really really strong
about people going to trade and I think
just in general the nation is really
trying to encourage people to do that
more because those people never are out
of a job and there's always a demand
like especially electricians right now
like there's not enough electricity
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
you know I am very sensitive to smile
and that's why I like Lumi because they
have a lot of options where it's just
all chill and it doesn't feel and smell
so strong and what's dope is they make a
deodorant that works all over your body
because sometimes you know like maybe
your arm might smell like [__] but your
armpits smell good and you can use it
all over you go like this and go oh yeah
it just neutralizes yeah your forehead
yep butthole penis vagina yup thighs
thighs yup Every Rose [__] bat wings
have you ever you guys know what a
Batwing is when it's a hot day and then
you're back touches your straight up
thighs and then when you spread it out
it just opens up and flaps yep anything
it's invented by OB GYN she made it for
the vagina so if it works for the vagina
it works for your eyelids everything the
Lumi starter pack is perfect for new
customers it comes with a solid state
deodorant a cream tube deodorant and two
free products of your choice like mini
body wash deodorant wipes and free
shipping that's a special offer for
listeners new customers get five dollars
off the Lumi starter pack with code OTR
at lumide.com that equates to over 40 of
your starter pack when you visit
lumide.com and use the code OTR and
you're learning directly what you're
gonna use yeah college is so theoretical
yeah and you're like you learn all this
Theory and you're like cool I think it's
it's cool I understand all that and then
I think the biggest gripe you hear
people say is once they graduate they
literally use nothing they learned in
college but you that's not true but in
trade school it's like you learn exactly
it's very specific yeah same with like I
think obviously the dream is to go to
stem field if you're like going to
college at all like that's probably a
better guaranteed result but in terms of
like other decisions like artistic or
creative that's borderline like if you
figure out while you're there how to not
be there yeah and still do that that is
the better choice yeah but you have to
figure that out that's the hard part
because I dropped out of UCI to compete
for America's best answer that's so
that's like worth it to me yeah yeah
like because I was like oh I think I can
just do this but
um but then I was there for journalism
and then I I left with well I have one
semester and now here you are back in
journalism
full circle yeah the real one but that
was one of those things too where I had
teachers in college that were also
sensible enough to tell like every
teacher that I had in journalism was
very
um much a realist and they were like
technically if you can write now then do
it oh it's awesome that's tight yeah
because uh they were saying like you're
just an author on a page no one's like
how old is that person how much do they
know like if you can write it it's
written like it's the body of work it's
this and she's like yeah I mean I can
write it it's written yeah
that
was right before she told me about the
dip Dodge duck diamonds
she's very redundant but which was great
but that like uh I think the worst part
about college is the illusion that you
need it yeah
and it depends on who's yeah it depends
who's saying it but if the system is
saying it and culture is saying it
that's harder I think it's better if
someone sensible is telling you oh you
need this if you want this but then the
idea as a collective where it's a given
that like oh in order to be a successful
person that's where it's not true yeah
yeah and especially especially nowadays
too it's like you have to keep in
question if you're going to
um take on debt like comparison another
game yeah yeah like really taking that
into consideration of what are you gonna
study what are you gonna come out with
it like and how much debt you're willing
to take on because I think when you're
young you think like okay it's gonna be
fine but afterwards it's a big weight
over your shoulders that you you have to
always deal with yeah you started you
start life at a negative we'll think of
like film school for for instance I use
this example for people like who want to
go to film school
um of course there's always going to be
pros and cons going to school some
people may come out of it with more
knowledge than others
um but with Film School particularly I
think the money that you spend on school
spend it on your gear
spend it on your equipment and now you
have the tools that you need to actually
execute the things that you're going to
work on yeah and you can get like
in
um experience on the job and you can
rent your own gear up you can rent it
out right so just now you own it and if
worst case you sell it and then you go
to school yeah I'm definitely
um I'm more of a like dude just do what
you want like I'm not for or against
College because for me
um I went to Community College and I
also stopped for the exact same reason
because of ABDC idiot and I was like
when is this opportunity ever gonna
happen again I'm Quinn school I'm
quitting my job I'm just gonna go do
this and then when I was done with the
show I was like do I want to go back to
school that because then that was
another question it's like okay but what
do I really want to do and it always
comes back to the question of what do
you really want to do and then once I
realized you know what like what about
what if it's not what about what I want
to do what if it's about what I can do
right now because of my opportunities
that I have right now yeah yeah it's
like I can definitely go back to school
or I can dance because this dance thing
is only gonna happen now sure yeah very
true I just picked the thing that I know
for sure I'm not going to get this
chance again yeah that's that's really
good way of seeing it yeah unless you
want to be like a lawyer or a doctor or
something that you actually really need
yeah yeah yeah
if you lawyered it you lied it yeah
because
you write it it's written
wow this is just mind-blowing yeah
the option to go back to school is
always going to be there it's never
gonna go away because there's always
going to be and they'll always want your
money dude that's right yeah that's like
yeah come back and of course we love to
have it also like know how you learn
some people aren't good in the classroom
setting yeah um yeah you know some
people learn better by Hands-On or
figuring problems out like on the job
yeah you know what actually not uh going
to college I only went for like a
semester but not going to college after
experience what college was like I was
like dude I really actually love
learning so let me try my best to learn
what I can from my travels from just
experience and whatever just soak it all
in and still try to gather knowledge
because I knew that that was the point
of college right is to learn you're
really good at it because you've done
you've had your own um you had Dusky
Hunters you had like your music now you
have your editing gig like you you're
just you've yeah you're going company
yeah whatever you pick up you like
Master it dude thanks thanks I had my
own like Journey almost of like
different feelings for it so when I
first got into college it was like I
needed it because I was it was pre-med
so I have to go to college we have to go
to graduate school then I started doing
JK with Joe and then there's this whole
time where like I really hated it and
almost my second and third year was like
all theater or film classes
and I'm like man when I get out but I'm
like so close to graduating and then
that was the time I would see like 1050
delegetto drop out of college Camp jumbo
dropped out of college everyone was just
like just dropping out of college I'm
like man should I do it but I didn't
have the balls too so we ended up
graduating and then we started doing JK
and then when because I think I had such
a like negative feeling towards it when
we're doing JK and it's all about
pursuing their passions I was like man
you don't need college like you could
just go and if you figure out what you
want you just get after it 100 and then
um I had a very like you don't need
college type of mentality
and then I remember we started touring
the nation and uh I would start doing
shows at all kinds of colleges State
schools Ivy Leagues whatever and I'm
like oh [__] and we had this
conversation yesterday when I'm like
dude some of these kids that go to the
top schools they're a different breed of
kid and like for example we're at Brown
University which is the Ivy League
school and then we had dinner with one
of the kids and he's a junior and then
oh like what are you doing your free
time I was like created this thing
called The Bite card what's a bike card
and he pulled out a credit card and on
the corner it was like a bit like almost
like a like by a cartoon character he
goes what I did is I went to all the
um like eateries and restaurants in this
neighborhood and I'm like can can we do
an arrangement where if like these kids
they pay they pay like the
subscribership and then it's automatic
like 15 or 20 off at BJ's uh like
Chick-fil-A whatever and I'm like you
did that as a [__] Junior which is
like well in 20 or 21 in college
while he's pre-med oh my this is just a
different level of kids it's like
innovators yeah yeah so like when we
when we would speak at Stanford or speak
out whatever I'm like okay like these
places like this is literally like a
think tank for the Future Leaders of
America you guys need to assemble and be
here yeah like for someone like me like
I was probably just filling a seat so I
don't know if I really needed college so
I had that like eye-opening experience
I'm like if you get if you get into the
top colleges
like that is a portal to the next level
like you guys are going to be senators
and you know crazy [__] like that then
afterwards after that period I started
like looking at the way that I structure
my life and I'm like you know what I
think the biggest thing I actually took
away from college is kind of like being
able to look at things from a macro
point of view and long distance because
I think usually it's like dude how do I
lose weight in two years everything's so
short you know and then usually the
biggest thing that anyone has ever even
thinked about a time frame is college
four years yeah six years yeah yeah or
like six years however long and that was
the first time I was like you know what
like because of college it made me be
able to look at something what do I want
to accomplish in four years how does
that break down into every year every
quarter every semester down to the day
almost like okay if I want to do this I
need to do this every Tuesday and
Thursday at 10 A.M your own graduation
of life exactly and so that's how I
started like um structuring my and then
I looked back on oh that's how I
structure my life like if I want to get
it like when I talk to uh Nick about Jiu
Jitsu I'm like I'm not going to commit
the Jitsu unless I'm do Tuesday
Thursdays this time and then I'll do
that for five years straight but that
ability to think like that that kind of
like mental infrastructure I'm like oh
[__] I don't think I would have had it
had I not gone to college I kind of have
like this full circle now where I'm like
I think I was one of those kids that
needed college to be able to look at
what's my Big Goal over a long period of
Time how do I break it down and then how
do I take the individual classes that
lead to the actual course that lead to
the degree like your life degree you
know yeah yeah right that's actually a
really good way to think yeah you know
what you can also tell people that are
questioning whether they should go to
college or not and pursue the dream I
actually would tell them if you can do
both do both like go to college and on
your free time do your other thing you
don't necessarily have to give up one or
the other right just do both if you can
fit it if it works yeah like if you like
it enough you would manage the time
properly to get it all you'll make it
work right definitely that's true
[Music]
thank you